la conférence de presse de la guignolée
des médias ressembler à une réunion des
chevaliers de la table ronde prêts à en
découdre avec la pauvreté et la pandémie
mais oui votre thérapie une douzaine de
porte parole vont s'assurer que le
message gagne toutes les couches de la
société
cette année c'est particulier il n'y a
pas cette journée où tous les médias se
mettent dans la rue à mazet denrées
amassées sont en europe et ce autant
qu'il faut pallier faut trouver d'autres
façons cette année aussi des gens qui
auraient donné les autres anémique cette
année vont devoir en bénéficier richard
d'anneaux de moisson montréal confirme
que la crise sanitaire à fragiliser
davantage le tissu social avant la cage
vide 7,6 canada dec et moral était la
grande ville canadienne où il y avait le
plus haut taux de sécurité alimentaire
depuis ce temps allait les besoins
alimentaires à montréal ont augmenté de
35 à 40 pour ça
tout au long de son ascension dans le
monde des affaires et de la télévision
nicolas duvernois a maintenu un lien
très étroit avec jeunesse au soleil
rapidement sa vision de la pauvreté a
volé en éclats ça m'a choqué parce que
je croyais que la pauvreté ça se voyait
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus insidieux
que ça elle ne se voit pas être tout le
monde donc peut vivre des moments a dit
si chez nous c'est vraiment difficile et
la jeune française et youtube aux
marinas bastarache entretien pour sa
part un lien privilégié avec les 18 35
ans elle s'est donné comme défi de les
mobiliser sans peut-être un peu
déconnecté de la radio la télé tout ce
sont vraiment plus sur le web mais je me
dise pas parce qu'on est deux jeunes
professionnels qu'on peut pas donner la
guignolée des médias comptent plus que
jamais sur la grande générosité de ceux
et celles qui sont en mesure de
contribuer du cl oui de béval radio
canada montréal